oh merde excusez moi ah ah ah je suis
quoi aussi je me regardais les épi
taione bizarre
[Musique]
la figuration libre c'est une expression
même a noté par ben vautier à 1989 pour
dénommer le travail
robert combas et moi-même fusion et
auxquels se sont rajoutés mon ami
françois warhol et rémi blanchard il ya
eu une grande exposition au musée d'art
moderne de la ville de paris à 87
justement avec les années 80 fait de la
figuration libre français et les quatre
américains c'est-à-dire le caniche à
keith haring jean michel basquiat les
clash moi j'étais un fan nourrit de la
bande dessinée de nu venant de nos
univers de milieux modestes
j'ai découvert je suis allé pour la
produire à falaise le musée j'ai vu pour
le premier enfant batiscan à 18 ans je
rêvais à paris que cela bobo par exemple
et donc j'ai été nourri de toute cette
imagerie de tout ça des pochettes de
disques de rock
j'étais j'avais 17 terrains swat et 17 c
la lave à la vague punk avec tout ce
tout le tout l'esthétique au tour ce
n'est pas que la musique avec une
esthétique avec des groupes comme le
bazou pas justement je suis très heureux
d'exposer l'équipe katyusha clavet cela
l'exposition psychédélices je me
rappelle le pitch je voulais dire
l'affect deux fois ça me l'a fait ça
hahaha
[Musique]
normes parce que pas que pas que parce
qu'il ya aussi la psilocybine ya
beaucoup de drogue me sert à prendre
d'une part mais c'est surtout un art qui
viennent c'est un peu je trouve la suite
du surréalisme tout cas c'est une des
jeunes femmes putatif du surréalisme le
psychédélisme c'est des artistes qui
veut le repousser les portes de la
perception et de la création dont il y
en a qui utilisent bien sûr des drogues
comme d'autres utilisent et alcool dans
les années le début du 20e siècle et ses
histoires d'artistes actuels colis que
là il y en a il y en a des centaines
mais il y en a aussi qui ont utilisé la
méditation il y en a qui ont utilisé la
réflexion l'étude
par exemple le grand artiste écrivait mi
are in show qui a donc il ya des pièces
de l'exposition ainsi qu'à nice aussi
lui a fait une expérience sous lsd
à noter scrupuleusement chaque heure
chaque dessin qui faisait avec et tout
ça ça a été c'est vraiment scientifique
après il y en a d'autres qui étaient
beaucoup plus poétique et puis d'autres
comme enrico ou ne le pas qui était pas
qu'ils n'avaient pas forcément une
relation avec avec cet univers de
pharmacopée quoi
[Musique]
à investir non mais ça me une part ça
m'interroge
deuxièmement je pratique la palette
graphique depuis une certaine tard et je
trouve c'est une un débouché pour ça
parce que je trouve que les impressions
de mes oeuvres que je fais directement
sur palette graphique c'est qu'une
impression le l'original c'est des
hommes et des zéros dans le disque danak
les coastal original et là le l'original
c'est vraiment le le code en fait c'est
ce qui se passe au niveau image moins au
niveau objets mais quand même au niveau
image
il ya des créations extraordinaires
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
non on a peur de ne pas finir